you know what the best way to solve
disappointment is what success the
reality is is this there was a couple
themes and they are that excited me hey
I have a very big thesis that if you are
a Jordan and LeBron fan you also highly
are likely to be lazy which you admitted
in there which excites the [ __ ] out of
me I think you need to fall in love with
the process of the grind versus the
anxiousness of getting there
like the celebrating is not the fun part
the process of getting there is you
don't love the process I'm about to [ __ ]
with everybody's heads really quick here
the reason I love people who stick with
their towns teams is the journey to
finally get good is so much more
intoxicating than being good the reality
is is you've got to fall in love with
the [ __ ] the people who never get lazy
sometimes are obsessed with the process
of what they're up to I have never ever
gotten lazy sometimes because I've been
addicted to everything I've done post
school I got lazy all the time in school
because I hated it so you get to major
decisions you know this is children of
immigrants we have two major decisions
who we love and what we choose to do
I'll say that again who we love ie who
you marry that's a big deal in our
community and what you do at 18 the
majority of my American friends yes
you're free to do whatever you're
literally forced to move out of the
house so those two I understand okay I
understand we are property of our
fathers I am property of not doing that
but you know I mean there was a big
fight to be right this is who I'm
marrying and this is what I'm choosing
to do it was a fight because immigrant
parents are like no no I own you [ __ ]
you talking about your shoes I own you
let me do what I want my totally this is
my thing though you're too big battles
are those two bad battles don't worry
about the money don't worry about all
that stuff you have
do those two things on your own terms
and you got an air mattress it if you
really love it otherwise you're a
fair-weather foam van that's the way
it's gonna or or actually by the way or
it might be like that wasn't your
destiny that what you wasn't really what
you wanted to do anyways but don't get
into some risks that you don't want to
do and don't don't um pursue engineering
or whatever because they're forcing you
to make all those decisions on your own
terms
neither a better or worse you know what
the best way to solve disappointment is
what success right like I have a funny
thing that yes so like but here's the
funny part
you're in the first quarter and you
think the game's over it was not fun for
me every time my parents disagreed I
live the same life like it's the same
game just a different skin tone I feel
like I get it but the reality is is like
[ __ ] you dad like that's real now I
highly recommend you say dad I love you
with all my heart and I know for a fact
everything coming out of your mouth is
what you want for me and it's how you
see it but pops you did your [ __ ] let me
do mine let's postgame this in 30 years
then we can judge you can literally win
at 42 and then be like told you you
either go to the wedding and grandma and
and grant aunt and great-aunt are
[ __ ] on you and you either hear that
and say I can't wait to stick it down
your [ __ ] throat in 2029 or you say
woe is me this blows I like the first
one and I think it's an interesting
debate of how they're actually the same
and how you train yourself to think is
an interesting thing twenty eighths of
fun a year to me 27:28 like I'm reading
a lot of content this 28 27 29 like and
30 33 like this kind of interesting age
group where like people make this funny
switch when they turn 27 and think that
are old when they're obnoxiously young
that comes from sure so 18 you leave you
have independence from 18 to 30 really
right around 30 people are getting
married in here kids yeah
so you're entering that we have life
like what am i doing
yeah I get it no no so alright the songs
that I planted have they manifested I
get it this is my advice for artists
the thing with artists is you do this
the rest of your life percent that's the
crazy part like Dave I agree was doing
comedy until he died
yep in his 80s that's right that's the
game same with filmmakers sane old
entrepreneur yeah it's why I feel bad
for athletes right I used to think it
was the best right like James Harden's
gonna be done at 36 forever he was
mentally I mean what we don't talk about
go show me all the brown kids all the
Russian kids that are 60 and 80 with
their parents I know the 60 and 80 year
old relationships that are broken cuz
the six-year-old followed the 80 year
old and they've had 35 years of [ __ ]
relationship because they didn't marry
that girl right right because they
didn't try that thing and so I think the
short-term pain of a band-aid rip yeah
versus cancer that happens in the back
half of every one of these people's
lives is an important conversation that
isn't being debated enough
[Music]
you
you